[Music]
welcome back to Sweetwater secrets I
have missed you river babe so much now
this is your preview episode for number
207 chapter 20 tales from the dark side
as always I'm your host Lee and I Galera
and today I'm showing some fierce
affections for my favorite pussycat
because this week Josie is finally
getting some much-needed screen time
what now to celebrate I'm bringing you
an exclusive interview with Ashlee Marie
where she dropped some brand new secrets
in our burgers and lives Fast Five we're
also gonna be breaking down the promo
for chapter 20 and teasing what's ahead
for this week's special three-part
episode but first I just want to say
thank you again so much for all of your
Sweetwater secret support and for
shouting out so many amazing hisses and
kisses in the comments now it seems like
you're not the only one who enjoys that
segment check out this adorable
behind-the-scenes moment from my chat
with Ashley where I first told her about
how she's the inspiration for hisses and
kisses you're doing a brand-new
riverdale after-show what's called
Sweetwater secrets topics and I got
invited my fight up you're gonna be on
it oh my gosh oh my god okay okay okay I
came up with with you and mine is called
kisses and kisses mm-hmm and I'm gonna
be listing my favorite moments at the
episode the moments that I maybe wasn't
quite too pleased with yeah so yeah so I
need to get your approval because my
producers want me to practice my kissing
and you just gave a really great rare oh
I did I'm gonna rewrite you just gotta
like go for it it's gotta be just like
really sharp and simple real rare there
it is you got it yeah I thought that my
shirt will pick it all up
yes again you do you got like it you
always get damn I love her so much
and I loved reading all of your comments
now here are a few of my faves alright
guys now
Rowan about 3:30 said hisses to Cheryl's
mum for not being there for her earlier
kisses to Tony for coming out as
bisexual yes Cheryl for embracing her
true drag queen
and finally for buddy for talking to
Veronica and Jughead about what's really
been happening bug had got together well
hopefully I agree girl but on the flip
side geyser ezio said I wish the
reconciliation between Veronica and bug
head was shown and not just implied I
mean this is a really important moment
in those relationships yes I completely
agree and I'm still waiting for bug head
to talk all about Tony so we can have
one of these moments now Cassie Bell
added I used to despise Tony but now I
love her because she represents the
LGBTQ community
yes representation and Halle gold Thorpe
left two great comments the first is I
love this show it's the highlight of my
week and can Betty find her mom's old
jacket and become the Queen slash
princess of the south side that would be
amazing
now Halle also said hisses to Archie my
goodness can the guy just do something
that helps nope apparently not
Nicole Bakari said 2:06 was her favorite
episode and she added love these videos
of sweet water secrets I feel the hard
work behind it and it's something
special and it's really amazing to be
able to talk with a fan and not just an
interviewer thank you so much Nicole I
really have a blast producing sweet
water secrets for you River babes and
you know I have an interview in the cast
since way before the first episode even
premiered so I'm so happy that you guys
feel like I'm part of the phantom moving
on all right guys now looking ahead to
the preview promo for episode 207 now
this shows Betty pointing all the
fingers at her latest black hood suspect
I have a theory
sure but to me that just clearly means
that sheriff Keller is not the black
hood you know I'm still looking at you
how Cooper let's just talk about this so
Riverdale showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa had tweeted the episode
207 is like a Halloween episode and it's
gonna feature three mini stories
ever since if I could walk into this
diner now one Center on Archie and jug
one on my girl Josie finally and based
on the promo it looks like we'll be
getting our last B&B team up now we're
also getting the return of Chuck Clayton
the womanizing creepy first met in
season 1 and now it seems like he has
his sights set on Josie Chuck Clayton as
community you know I'm pretty peeved
that Josie has been left out of the
season 2 spotlight so far because in my
opinion this character has so much more
to offer than just a pretty voice now I
also wanted you guys to have the
opportunity to get to know Ashley Marie
even more so I challenged her to answer
our burgers and lies Fast Five take a
look
[Music]
so I'm gonna give you a series of five
questions okay you're gonna answer them
fast and furious okay Besson fiercely
are you you're in a diner what is your
go-to order cheese fries oh yes and they
wrote that into an episode for you
because it's true
I mean you do love your cheese fries
Josie which couple on the show are you
currently shipping
oh I don't ship okay I do not ship it's
dangerous I do that please take him
are there any dynamics that you enjoy um
I enjoy Cheryl and Kevin's dynamics
they're so funny they're just which of
your cast mates would you trust you the
secret tell me a secret
about one of the Riverdale sets Oh place
you like to go and sneak off to
somewhere for a little alone time I
don't um but I did just discover a
monkey lamp it's like it's the creepiest
hear no evil do no evil speak no evil
monkey they look like long orangutan is
just like around each other doing the
thing and I don't know why it's in a
high school lounge but it is that's
that's the strangest thing I think I can
tell you in real life are you a vixen a
serpent or a pussycat and why oh well
I'm a pussycat in real life let's that's
the honest I'm not that limber to be a
vixen I mean like I could throw on a
serpent jacket if you need me to I can
run like full speed in four and a half
inch heels so I I guess that also makes
me a pretty awesome
this is very true plus there's no way
she can be a surfer because guys she's
the nice to not love her all right guys
now that does it for this week's preview
episode of Sweetwater secrets now hit
the comments right now and tell me all
of your theories about what you think is
gonna happen in episode 207 then check
back with me after you watch chapter 20
tales from the dark side for exclusive
behind-the-scenes scoop from Ashlee
Marie and Madeline Pech and even more
kisses and kisses guys please give this
video a like share it with your friends
and don't forget to click the link and
ring the bell in my comments below so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets Tata for now river babes
[Music]